foreign
we might be drunk oh it's happening hey
we're doing it yeah thanks thanks for
coming in you're a West Coast queef and
now you're here with us Pacific
Northwest
yeah I'm an organ boy now whoa whoa REI
pal books I mean Arya is pretty National
yeah we got one of those yeah sure I
just say like there's a lot of tents out
there you know I don't think they're
buying new I got a lot of duct tapes a
lot of hand-me-downs it's more of a
Dick's Sporting Goods kind of crowd yeah
what prompted the move to Portland
pandemic had a chance to move up there
and then just uh
been there for since the beginning of it
and I'm like yeah this is good no this
is all right yeah as I was saying before
I'm like I'm not part of like I do
comedy but I'm not really a showbiz
like I never even before pandemic
they're like hey man you want to drive
to Santa Monica for an audition I was
like no no no I won't yeah I've been to
China to do stand-up but I will not
cross the 405. do a paper towel
commercial I'm not into that scene man I
hate every audition and I enjoy now
because I'm such a [__] that I'll get
an email from my agent like hey this is
a good role for you it's uh whatever
show Criminal Minds you'd be perfect for
it I'm like I don't want to do it [__]
it I'm saying no what part of Criminal
Minds do they think wow what role are
you getting on Criminal Minds The
autistic serial killer there's a couple
of singers they said you don't even have
to audition yeah we wrote it for you we
wrote it for you right yeah it's tough
but also doing the road out of the West
Coast is always tougher just with the
time change if you're coming east to go
a day early right you're behind the
eight ball there yeah I'm like I love a
red eye oh you're the one I sleep yeah I
sleep on the plane I snore on the planes
have a couple drinks before I get to the
airport couple drinks on the airport
sorry I said I wish I would have saved
mine I had a bunch that you specifically
got pleather seats yeah they crack off
real nice
man that blew this way I appreciate it I
don't think you're sorry I know you just
farted
didn't mean it to blow on you I mean I
mean you did point it that way but I
think you got to vent I appreciate you
blowing it in my direction that smells
like it smells healthy oh yeah Chipotle
like we make it through the almonds
pretty good over there but you're on the
road pretty hard regularly
I'm cut yeah I'm kind of changing it up
I just like okay I just
was tired by this like
you see everybody like you see everybody
hustle you know everybody's crying and I
get here and everybody's like I got four
sets tonight I got six sets tonight I'm
like that sounds like hell guys that
sounds like a living hell to me I don't
like myself or hate myself enough to
hear that much in my own voice all right
and uh
yeah I'm not like a social media guy so
I'm like oh I've actually like having a
lot of fun nobody would know
because I'm not celebrating it on
Instagram right right oh yeah this time
off
pretty tight it's pretty nice but you
have a you have a core fan base like you
got a group that'll see you anywhere I
got a tiny little group out there like I
I've gotten this big realization of like
there might not be super stardom but
what if I just make as much as like a
good electrician oh that's living like
what if I make just a solid living and
uh and that's it and then I get however
much off I want to hear I like I think
it's I don't know I agree I'd get
jealous of people like oh look at
like people are blowing up and getting
all that stuff but I'm like but do I
want to do all this stuff that they
exactly it's a balance you gotta give
and take like like a guy like sagora you
know millions of dollars a year Arenas I
don't know if I'd want that that worries
me I get anxiety just thinking about
that not that I'm going that way you
know he's very talented but like I I
don't know I just that's not the
direction we're choosing yeah I want to
fart on a pleather couch and hang with
you guys you did you have a sponsor your
production here dude don't you have your
own whiskey yeah for the fart cast here
I've never sense of smell anymore
because of you you're welcome that's a
shame because there's whiskey you know
it smells tied to taste you know you
can't even enjoy the product me or
covert one of one of us [__] your
smell but I don't know that the fame
where Fame scares the [__] out of me
that just doesn't seem fun I've opened
for famous people and running through
restaurants and running through airports
and hiding thank you I don't know thank
you I would say that you guys are
doing pretty great it's a good level
though it's a nice easy level we get a
little the good and you still got to do
the work hey cheers
I know what mark means I mean yeah we
both like you know open for Amy Schumer
back in the day we both I mean she was
doing Arenas at the time yeah it's like
it is like a a level I'm like oh that
would be uh that would be hard to be to
stay
I mean how do you work out material in
Arena I just it's right yeah at what
point is it too big that it's
unmanageable exactly because those are
weird to see not a high energy act in an
arena like I saw I was in St Louis and
Chris Rock was in St Louis so I went to
watch the show afterwards and it's weird
to see a comic doing the type of Comedy
Rock does in an arena you're just used
to seeing like I picture like a
Sebastian like a type of comic you don't
picture like rock is saying like
philosophical [__] on stage and you know
having to repeat the setup because it's
not the type of economy you probably
would normally see in an arena I don't
think he's new to repeating setups
I think it's kind of been a sting for a
while but still it's not the type of
Comedy you normally see in a venue like
that you know yeah yeah I don't well
this is I mean of course coming from a
place from a guy who's still doing clubs
I don't know I think you can get too big
of a venue for comedy it's like what a
what a wonderful thing to criticize that
it's true though I agree I bombed uh I
bombed opener for the Impractical Jokers
at the same venue I saw lalapalooza in
1994. yeah like I was the same stage I
saw the Beastie Boys on and I'm trying
to do comedy on it I did it to myself
like even before I went out I'm like I
don't think this is gonna work and then
I fulfilled my own destiny you were the
Hoobastank of that love palooza I was 12
000 people but a woman walking to her
seat in the front row with two beers I
was talking about like yeah I saw a
smashing pump because I actually fell
asleep in those seats right there during
Smashing Pumpkins a woman in the front
row with two beers just goes that was a
great show [__] you
even though
eleven thousand nine hundred fifty
people didn't hear it I was like [__]
this whole crowd I don't give a [__]
anymore bombing in an arena I've done it
it is that silence is powerful I had the
sweat tripping about my back I had the
the dry mouth oh you're like brutal I
might do something else yeah I was like
shell-shocked in the green room after I
was like oh my God I couldn't get tough
though too the joke I bombed in front of
the Jokers have you it's like yeah this
makes me feel better that's kids well
yeah they're not it's like a family
thing they're like we're here for the
Jokers it's not a stand-up crap yeah
yeah then they're set they're so it's 12
000 people outside getting settled with
their merch and beach balls and drinks
yeah and you're like no no listen it's
the way the words it's the it's an
enunciation yeah it's a subtlety to it I
watched I've watched a lot of your [__]
and it's pretty bulletproof so if it's
not working for that right oh man you
should have been at most of my sets this
week where were you
uh
it bounce around here I just like I'll
do like some drop-in sets but it's like
I don't have my sea legs out here and I
get I get in my own way I get my own
heads I'm like oh I gotta be like
edgy because it's New York but then I'm
on like I still get booked on like the
sensitive alternative shows I'm like
wrong choice and then I'll not know that
I'm on the edgy show and I'm like you
guys ever just just think about life
right I'm like wrong show like I did not
I can didn't get here in time I wanted
to read the room I didn't have the
chance we were talking about this
earlier I felt like I started in the
creek and the Brooklyn shows and the
Whiplash and all that [__] I was like
clubbier and you were Club I had to work
off some like Club stank and he had to
work off some alt thing oh yeah where's
the middle I think we're all kind of
like getting to the middle at this point
because we're walking the road exactly
if you live in the city you can have
your little niche here right like I do
these rooms I do those rooms and now
it's like well no I do the runs that pay
me yeah for a living and I kind of got
to win new people over in those rooms I
gotta win over the dates but yeah we
hear the stories about like Louie and
Marin and natel and they were coming up
here in like the 90s they did all the
rooms I think we all wanted to be is you
know yeah you want to be funny for
everybody yeah I think I just want to
quit
back off live in the country but that's
the thing you're so goddamn prolific
like you always have new [__] and a lot
of it like it takes me so long to come
up with new material and hone it and
refine it but you always are pumping it
out
I I mean
yeah I really like stand up like I
really love it but like the part I love
about it is coming up with new stuff
yeah like once something works you're
like okay that's good to have yeah but
now can I top it exactly and it's like
that's why I
I guess that's why I keep going I can't
do like I'm you know I can't like turn
my life into the reality show with the
phone like all I could do is turn out
new material because that's the part
that I'm attracted to in all of it and
uh you know for better or worse it's
hell sometimes sure because you go for
like
two months without writing a new bit
you're like it's all it's over yeah
that's the worst I Spy I stripped the
gear yeah because I'll be done now
people don't realize a new joke is like
an invention you have to invent
something out of thin air or something
has to happen to you and you can make it
funny and you have to tie it all up and
has to make sense and have a good ending
and a turn that they didn't see coming I
mean it's it's tough It's what you said
about doing the forza tonight like Mark
and I are definitely guilty of being
those types of people and sure and I
think we there's something we battle
with or like we forget to live life
sometimes yeah to have [__] to write
about and I don't think it's I don't
think it's bad to do four sets tonight
because you guys are gonna go you guys
gotta like my short game's gone oh
really I don't have a short game that's
sorry I'm spoiled I got doing an hour
it's 10 minutes of me you know around
the stage you're here for me everybody
loves me right and then I get here and
I'm just like getting the light and I'm
just like opening my notes like I don't
have a quick uh zingers
yeah sometimes because you'll be
following some new guy and you're like
[__] this dude's really good yeah and
we're going there trying to work on [__]
and it's like some new dude and you're
like this dude's playing the [__]
hits oh yeah in my first five minutes
now we're gonna be like kind of you know
in the [__] and then you're like it's
a 10 minute set I got lit at eight for
some reason the show's behind right I
know I just had a bad set yeah and then
your egos hurt and then the young guy is
going he's the good one come on I'm the
man okay can you do tomorrow night new
material oh [__] sorry exactly well
that's like on the road too you get like
I want to give local features an act
yeah because I I hear I mean I do bring
people like a lot of time also but you
hear them like yeah there's no way to
get Feature work in these towns because
everybody brings their own feature like
oh I do some weekends like yeah let's
see who they got and then I'm like oh oh
yeah they got some big hitters in this
town right they got this is their gig
this is their big gig at the club
exactly God damn it this is why I gotta
bring my own feature but I also want to
bring people that are still a challenge
to follow too for sure I bring Gary
veteran it's like just killer deadpan
jokes so it's like they're low energy
they have to listen yeah that's perfect
I love his jokes you know I had Sam
talent coming out with me I'm like what
the [__] am I doing myself I quit comedy
every night he is he's Force yeah I used
to have Sean Patton come out and look
before Sean Penn was shot and I'd sit
there I I quit comedy I think three
times on tour with Sean Patton like
legit like we'd be at a bar after I'm
like don't talk to me yeah I gotta go
listen to this musician play some sad
songs in the corner because my career's
over yeah and I get back underneath it
and you're like Well everybody's here to
have fun and I get in my head I get I
get in my head about it Sean Patton if
you uh criminally underrated uh yeah the
look of his stuff if you don't know one
of the one of the best Comics I've done
Road gigs with him where I'm like you
headline because he's just so high
energy and imaginative and he's all over
the place and I'm like and the stories
like twist and turn and then yeah he
he's I was watching the other night and
I was just like that's the thing I don't
watch a lot of specials anymore but if
I'm at the club and I'm following
someone sometimes I'll watch it sure and
I was just like laughing out loud oh
yeah he'll say some horrific [__] where
you're like where's this going yeah it's
some premise bug you know that a lot of
women orgasm when they give birth I'm
like oh God damn it dude what I mean I'd
have faith in you but yeah
[__] man like why'd you make us all
realize that and then it was crowd work
would you would you want your mother to
have an orgasm which I'm like this is so
so hard to watch and then it was
hilarious yeah he knows what he's doing
but oh that's great yeah Patton but Pat
Oswald different patent years ago said
that about you I don't know if you knew
that he's like you used to open for him
yeah and he was like this guy's killing
too hard and it's making it hard for me
well I knew it was
like what you guys said you got like
Schumer and everybody had like people
before like I'm not going to pull tricks
but this is a crowd that's here
especially for Pat and I was like this
is a crowd these are like comedy fans
right like these are the people are
gonna if they like you they're gonna
follow you yeah yes and I'm like these
are extra important people to do well so
I was like
and that's my like that's my advice to
opener like don't do
you know don't hot dog anything yeah but
you should try to bury me yeah because
because then then you win it's a
constant like
knock off you know you know whatever
Sports metaphor knockoff King of the
circle type [__] like oh you did good
then you should be getting paid for the
headlining spot like that's what you
should be doing and like that's what we
thought of when we were features I said
that and then Sam talent's like oh yeah
all right Sam come on
like shut the [__] up sometimes there's
something great about being in the green
room and you're like damn this guy's
[__] murdering and you're like all
right and you kind of have to like wake
up a little and go all right I gotta do
this now yeah I was in uh I was on the
road and uh James Webb we will film my
sets and he directed my last special and
he's like I was like we should give like
a local guy a spot do you know any local
guys here and he was like I got the guys
the best [__] comic you never heard
of this dude's a [__] killer and then
he's like I'm calling him you're gonna
have trouble following him is he coming
he goes he quit
quick comedy
so some of those guys burned out what do
you know do you remember who it was like
I forgot his name he was in Chicago
oh okay yeah damn but it was just like
he just came and hung but I was like
this is so funny he's like built them up
I was like I kind of wanted to see it
Joe Rogan quit
it's about time Joe Rogan started oh no
okay hey who's here to make friends I uh
I uh had that was Sam went oh we're okay
all right I'll catch up whoa easy big
papa all right I only got a set in seven
hours we'll see how this goes this is
our second show by the way
yeah Sam was like I was like doing some
gig where there was a curtain in the
bathrooms I'd do all these you know or
just do like I gotta do these Punk
venues and then you get there you're
like this is not a good place for comedy
oh yeah the bathroom is behind the stage
and there's a curtain and Sam's back
there and I'm on stage and I'm not doing
well because I got one of my long drawn
out [__] stories and there's a just
a guy seeing Santa that was just so it
was like amazing like I've never seen
comedy that funny and I'm on stage and
the audience can hear that guy
that's great through me with a
microphone and finally I just gonna open
the curl like I'm I'm right here oh like
the show's not over man damn I've had a
million of those the worst I think I've
told you this before I'm [__] at
Comedy Works I'm hosting Pete Holmes is
featuring and uh Amy Schumer's
headlining it's all sold out I did okay
Pete Holmes annihilates like the roof
came off and then she's killing and
these guys are washing their hands I'm
[__] in the stall and they're like
man that guy in the middle the tall guy
he was amazing and the other guy's like
I know I know and they're like and she's
killer too I'm dying over here and he
goes what about the host and I was like
and I go he sucks
I'm totally vulnerable and I go I
thought it was pretty good I'm trying to
like chime in if you come out or no no I
couldn't go out it happened to me once
you take your shoes off so they couldn't
see him
out of sight so I couldn't recognize you
yeah I lifted there's anything happen to
me years ago I was doing like a private
gig with Al lubella's headlining and he
was hilarious like really had killer
jokes and uh and they were like weird
one-liners and a unique guy like that
killing the stiff crowd I was like this
pretty damn impressive yeah I sucked and
I was in the I was in the bathroom I
heard them just saying how bad I was and
I was like I was waiting but they took
forever I was like [__] it I gotta I got
a face
and they're like sorry on my gas
let that be a lesson about talking [__]
without looking under the skulls yeah
that's how they just do it online to the
whole world yeah yeah be a faceless uh
comment yeah a lot of mean comments I
gotta stop reading them because I'm like
hey nice nice that ah I know not to
respond back but I still read them I
hate myself for it yeah I can't stop
Mark reads them all he reads every
comment oh yeah I get through a lot of
them do you what's your ratio of like
how you feel of good comments to bad
like a hundred good comments that's one
bad comment erased 100 good comments I'm
like yeah I'd say 100's about right it's
like why why am I like this what's the
guy in the front row doing this you know
you're killing but that one guy it's
like your Arena lady you're focused on
her do you look at the crowd no I go
right over the head yeah look at the
lights because then if I do look at the
crowd I've already blinded myself oh
that's pretty so I've had to risk my own
Vision rather than uh human interaction
also I'm more comfortable if I look at
them I feel like they go like oh he's
looking at us we have to laugh and I
don't want that fake smile you know I'd
rather get a real laugh yeah but
sometimes you look and you're like
you're just I don't know I just want to
make sure they're having fun sure I
guess that's I'll use my ears for that
in my eyes I'll just listen yeah and
then if they Heckle like all right well
now I have to judge you to tear apart
your appearance yeah see I can't you
guys are you guys dip into the crowd I
still yeah I won't do it I did it before
the internet stuff just because I no I
know I I've made my I've made I've been
loud on the internet how I feel about
Crower Clips but I also know like who's
been doing it and doing his part that is
the first thing you do in comedy like an
open mic where are you from no no no no
this is materials it's like when people
would just like have they'd be like
great Roasters but they didn't have five
minutes about it yes that was an
epidemic no I think I'd do it but I did
it because I was like you know I was a
big Dangerfield fan growing up and I
would like listen to Dangerfield he
would dip into the crowd and it was
because of his rhythm I think and I was
like oh I love that you know and you
know I think if you have short jokes it
it helps it breaks it up a little yeah I
set Don Rickles before he died that's
like watching somebody old do comedy and
you're kind of nervous like he started
repeating a couple bits and there's a
couple like that but then he looked he
just looked in the front row at this
couple he's like what are you holding
their hand for nobody's fighting over
because everybody was kind of like all
right we're watching this old guy kind
of do the thing and he busted down like
he's still got it back he's so excited
like [__] Rickles baby
it was
I mean for somebody it's like oh it's
Don Rickles and so you saw them those
glimmers of
like what Don Rickles always was you
were excited for that but a lot of it
was like uh we he said this one already
yeah okay that one's
wow banging on the stage with the thing
I gotta get him to row faster like yoza
everybody
else he's old let him have him
we know he does he means well yeah
that's gonna be a sad day when you see
David tell like start slipping you're
like oh no we're all getting old yeah
David tell the fastest gun in the west
is just like so Jaeger
already that set has to have happened at
like you know everybody has an off I've
done it I've done it when you have to do
like the St Louis Funny Bone or whatever
like three three yes or zany is the
three shows those are the ones where I'd
like by the show three I'd be like I
think I've said this one I've watched
I've watched people do it I used to like
go to Zanies in downtown Chicago just to
watch and then watch somebody on the
third show everybody in there is fall
down drunk the room is as big as a train
car yeah and the guy that stays like I
have five and they're like you shut it
already [__] you you'll listen again
then
this is my Pursuit this is my dream
right weird goal I've chosen the
smallest room but it's still like the
bet it's one of the best it's a great
room it's still one of my favorite rooms
but you need to I need to revisit it
because like when I started there they
weren't really putting up the locals
were a lot of weirdos
that now turned in you know you got your
Pete Holmes in your hands oh right stuff
like that but at the time it was that
was your classes those guys yeah yeah
and your class is insane by the way was
was Nick bad where I was a little after
you no Vatterott was the same time I
love that we love it he's underrated
it's very funny
oh that was a big one sorry
I love batter Rod I got it you have to
don't no don't back away from what you
did all right did you have to you have
to stand up for it well it wouldn't come
out with the pleather that's almost like
that would be better
it's almost like that would be good
I was sealed it's not coming this way
yet so oh it went to little things to be
grateful about
[Laughter]
it's like global warming still in the
ice caps yeah okay it gave me more
drinks so I guess that's a good thing
the louder it is actually the less it
stinks I think I don't know about that
all right I don't think there's a
correlation I think it's that way with
Comics before they stick
oh my god when a comic screaming it
[__] kills me oh yeah the other night
where you're just like they have four
rooms now so like those yeah I don't
know if you've been to the fat black bar
they have a bar show and uh just hanging
and just a comic screaming I'm like [__]
yeah when it when it messes with you
usually like that I don't get what
you're doing I know I think it just
means they're not that good so they have
to get your attention by screaming I
don't know that's tough
but I got a zany story
so were you not allowed in there were
you did you struggle to like get
breakthrough I was allowed in the
building well you know what I mean
no it wasn't it was I think they had
their Lo they had their hosts that were
great hosts that didn't do stand up
anywhere else
and then the they had their features
that occasionally got to do headlining
spots
that they were like kind of curating to
become a star and then the traveling
Headliners so all the local guys and we
were all doing goofball [__] you got
like a veteran like and so we get to do
guest spots like the manager Martine was
always awesome and he'd like always asks
we got a guy we like and I would do
guest spots but I was never gonna get
booked because I was a lousy at MC yeah
and it was one of those things like well
we can't put you past right to a feature
and so it's just it wasn't no there was
other like it wasn't
the goal it was kind of looked at is
like oh that's just what the old people
do oh interesting yeah because I uh I
did the open mic there and I don't know
if you've heard this this thing where
you go to the open mic and you have to
get there at a certain time and if
you're late
the owner yells at you and makes an
example out of you in front of everyone
yeah and I that was me so I couldn't get
in the door was locked and I was like ah
he was just like you got to be here at
six you got to be here at six I was like
he's like if you're a minute late don't
even come in and I was you know it's 5
56 I'm banging on the door no one's
answering so I run around the back and
uh that door is locked I'm like what the
[__] is this a trick and uh the door
swings open and some waitress with a
cigarette and she's like what do you
want I'm like I'm here for the open mic
she's like oh you're late I'm like it's
5 58 she's like yeah you got to be here
early and I'm like okay I run upstairs
burped you know Bert I don't know if I
should say his name bleep that gives a
[__] all right he's gone now but yeah
it's in this room The Green Room and all
the comics are there and they all have
manila folders with their head shot and
their resume and I'm like oh I don't
have that so he's like you're late how
dare you you come in here you disrespect
my club you disrespect me everybody else
got here early and he goes where's your
head shot I go I don't have a headshot
it goes and you don't have a headshot
you make me sick you're never gonna work
in this town again I ought to tell your
family you're a piece of [__] whatever
and I'm like oh and all the other
comments like oh [__] this is bad and I
leave and I was like coming to tears I
was like so angry and I was like I
should have chewed that guy out [__] him
cut two
six years later
I feature there and he doesn't remember
me and he's like hey welcome to the club
one I had a good set and he was like
we're gonna pass you or whatever so I
got passed at the club but I felt like
Jean valje you know like I got back in
and I was the mayor of the town but he
didn't know who he wouldn't know I was
the jail guy I uh I was there when they
didn't even have an open mic because
they didn't want people running around
saying they played zany you know people
just say that right they just lie
they're comedians they'll just lie oh
that happens you've seen this guy on
Comedy Central I uh when I went back you
know got made my bones went back as a
headliner and was on stage and I you
know that's like that's a Clubby room
it's a quick get him room and I was even
worse with my long stories of like well
if you missed the detail at the
beginning you're not gonna understand
them like I was pretty up my own ass
yeah but I'm doing it's a late show it's
going all right all of a sudden all the
way back in the bar here
scuffling going on oh my God what's
happening somebody just goes fight I'm
like all right what's the story like
it's cops
and uh Nate bargancy was just hanging
out in the back he was just all the way
in the back by the nacho cheese yeah and
uh he's like yeah it was like this is
the most Chicago [__] thing because
that place was Notorious for being like
this spot that was paid off and oh like
like back in the day and so these cops
got in with their dates and they're all
in the back and some guys you know
sitting there it's a very small place
and this gal tried to go to the bathroom
and I guess like tripped over his foot
and was just shitty to him about it
because she wasn't looking where she was
going
he's like why'd you [__] watch where
you put your legs you [__] he's like
why'd you stop being a [__] and then a
guy goes you can't say that I'm a cop
he's like yes I can oh boy that's not
what you can do as a cop and then [__]
went down and then the regular cop
showed up to support their buddies
clearly put the dude who was in the
right put him in cups yeah now they're
leading everybody I'm on stage the whole
time
now they're leading people out through
the front door which is right next to
the stage and I had friends from like my
hometown in the front row I'm like yeah
this is what it looks like when my
dreams come true
that's so proud to tell me like yeah
that was like a big marker like your
headline and say like just for people
that didn't know anything of course yeah
and like man this is it's just it's I
just kind of shout over bar fights yeah
but that doesn't happen to cats you know
or or Les Mis or Wicked you know these
cops coming in fighting again I think it
has to there's got to be a story about
somebody yelling at cat like somebody
getting booted out of cats I hope I'd
love to hear it I guess they don't do
crowd work about it I did go I did go
see Rock of Ages in uh Las Vegas
fantastic uh nobody's gonna like this
movie or play musical yeah you know what
it is right oh yeah yeah and uh one guy
with Def Leppard and stuff yeah it's a
musical about the Sunset Strip in the
80s it's my wheelhouse and uh
there's a guy that was just so drunk he
just kept thinking it was a concert and
he kept standing up to like sing the
songs like sir you can't interrupt the
performance he's like they're [__]
playing the tunes man and I kept talking
I'm like I'm kind of on his side they're
they're doing a good job it's in one of
these big like Arenas in Vegas there's
like 50 people in there oh I was doing a
I was doing punk rock bowl like a punk
rock festival I was sick of punk rock at
that point of the week and I'm like I'm
going to see rocket ages by myself yeah
I'm with these like you know these older
ladies and taking in a show they think
I'm going through a thing because I got
a Vegas show alone and then they get to
the ballads and I'm like drunk and kind
of feeling like the journey Tunes maybe
like getting emotional yeah and this one
lady just kept knocking over my beer
because she's dancing right and then I'm
leaving they're like I'm so sorry honey
and they look she gives me like 50 bucks
I'm like I'm not I'm fine like
everybody's fine
really thought
I thought had to go sing 80s rock band
best show of the weekend there you go I
love the guy who thinks it's a concert
do you think it's a lady of cats with
like two cats she's like I thought
that's what we did here
I wish that something like that happens
like no the Run of these perform like
every comedian has a story about [__]
going wrong musicians have something
crazy I guess Broadway's got its batch
of [__] shoes
I hope I don't dress up like cats to go
to cats yeah people do that right
somebody must be in a Hamilton outfit
like a full-on you know uh well that's
as bad as it gets and they're [__]
lucky I would think there's some bad
[__] to that but I think like most of
their stories are like I lost my voice
and I still did the show I feel like
it's much less about hecklers right yeah
I don't think it heckled a ton I got I
really came around on uh
like musical theater like do you go to
it just as a thing to do because you're
in New York you're like let's go take a
show I grew up with it you're from here
yeah but I love you so my mom loved that
stuff but yeah I've if I'm dating the
girls into it it's a date I don't go
with like my guy friends but like
there's a girl it's like a thing to do
yeah you know do something silly go to
see a show yeah yeah I ain't grow up at
all no I like I go and I see like how
much effort is but like it makes you
feel so small as a comedian to see like
all these people not only learn lines
but are singing them and know where to
stand yeah this giant prop doesn't come
and knock them off the stage then they
run then they change costumes somebody
made the costume yes I look at all that
and I think about how like oh I'm pretty
tired
way harder like we can go on stage hung
over we go on stage feeling like [__]
you see like I just I saw company on
Broadway it's amazing it's a great show
but uh what's can you look up the
woman's name in it she's she's famous
you'd know her name if you heard it but
my dad I took bot tickets Daddy [__]
loved it company yeah it's so [__]
it's like fun it's Sondheim it's funny
it's great music God what's it Patty
LuPone oh she's gonna be in her 60s but
she's moving around the whole time and
I'm like that's it's incredible I
couldn't do that oh yeah
these people all have like Juilliard
they dance they sing they got it all
where's your what like speaker they're
like What's your life then do you like
get up and do stuff during the day I
think Oh you mean they go ballet and
[__] but I mean like during the day is
that do you have I think they have to be
really careful and just really healthy
probably go to the gym maybe like light
light gym yeah I mean you're like this
is like you're basically it's like
you're an astronaut like your life is
about training to do the thing yes and
then you do the thing and then you get
shot into space or you're on Broadway
for four months and people come from
Cleveland and all these places to watch
and they pay hundreds of dollars to see
you
you know high kick but there's
definitely shows like I don't know I'm
gonna get over the fact that I bombed
for seven minutes the other night at a
Two Boots Pizza
not gonna take it so personal now
no fault of Two Boots it was a lovely
slice but we can definitely perform
longer than them although she's 74 and
still has 74. she looks good perform
longer like how well I'm just saying
because we have a one-man band it's just
us so we can go on you know Rickles is
up there at 88 or 90. you know
that's what Comics can do I mean it's
probably harder to get cast the older
you get but I mean uh she's I mean she's
been working forever what was she what
was what was her TV credit I know her
face was she uh she looks like Janet
Reno what was the what was the quirky TV
show life goes on was that her was she
life goes on whoa no wonder I'm hard
I haven't seen that in years for which
which part of life goes on hard for
Corky oh yeah I got a fetish hey guys
Peter's here producer for we might be
drunk I want to talk to you for a second
about we might be drunkpod.com it's the
merch store it's the website it's so
much stuff we added a couple new shirts
designs just this week we have the new
NBA Jam inspired design we have a cool
cat design we're always adding new
things there's so much stuff on the
website we might be drunkpod.com we have
T-shirts we have hats we have cups we
have posters stickers also if you want
20 off anything at the merch store then
you need to be on our patreon at
patreon.com we might be drunk pod you
get 20 off anything at the merch store
so sign up on that five dollar tier
that's basically gonna pay for itself
with one purchase of the merch store so
20 off we might be drunkpod.com
if you're a patron at patreon.com we
might be drunkpot when you get something
at the merch store when it comes in the
mail and you're so excited put that
shirt on snap a selfie send it over to
me at remember drunkpot gmail.com I will
post it on Instagram but if you want to
be frugal spend five bucks sign up for
the patreon you get all this bonus
content Early Access ad-free stuff you
can talk to me if you want 20 off if
you're a patron patreon.com you might be
drunk pod we might be drunkpod.com is
the place to go back to the show go
bills hey we love liquid death baby it
said liquid Death Mountain Water
flavored sparkling water iced tea I love
a tall boy can it's a non-alcoholic
choice that you can enjoy anywhere with
flavors like rest in Peach and armless
Palmer hey that's fun you can make it's
good stuff this it's Seltzer it's really
good I mean so good tall boy who are we
Kevin Spacey
it's a gift that keeps on giving now all
these all these sparkling drinks I mean
like you know New York Jew it's a it's a
stereotype but we love this stuff it's
just good good clean living right here
yeah you can mix it with cocktails if
you want to have a have a little booze
in there but it tastes great they go
down easy and nice summer summer drink
we drink them on here all the time
crack your can here right now what is
this one right here you got iced tea
looks like iced tea That's nice armless
Palmer Club I love the names are like
The Simpsons uh Halloween episodes
Dragon liquid death is also great for
the environment it's really [__] good
let me try that they donate a portion of
the profits from every canceled to help
end plastic pollution why would you
drink anything else pick up a case and
start violently murdering your thirst
today
you can find liquid death's healthy
beverages on Amazon or the real trailer
a retailer near you plus we might be
drunk listeners get 20 off their first
liquid death apparel purchase available
exclusively at liquiddeath.com drunk
exclusions May apply that's
liquiddeath.com drunk
I love a forehead life goes on there it
is wow oh I wonder how Corky's doing
these days yeah pull up Corky he's
probably passing the seller at this
point what is that
you don't know life goes on I've never
seen it oh wow all right you had a good
childhood
there he is yeah it's Corky I'm telling
you it's all him he's not Irish
[Music]
that's what's what you think it's not
he had a lot of move he got good credits
oh we did Mona Lisa Smile come on this
guy's killing it big cork Chris Burke
what was this show big Court he was the
special needs guy and life goes on yeah
like down syndrome fella yeah head of
the game
89. yeah we're older I think he ever
gets mad at being Typecast
he's not gonna play the uh born identity
you know maybe stillborn you never know
Jesus Christ
we're having fun
oh yeah so you you must love I'll throw
another drink on after that one yeah get
this guy down there you go thank you
beard you now uh you you must be happy
about the YouTube game we all got going
on here we're all a bunch of YouTube
hours over here same website more kids
open new Legos
what holds my career a few more million
hits than us
those guys are billionaires unbridled
enthusiasm for those Lego sets good for
them they're not jaded by life I don't
think that'll end well but yeah for now
they're having a great day it's a nice
option no I'm yeah I'm making jokes
about it but like it just let it just
let it be out there yeah yeah let's put
it on other labels like we want a shot
could label spent money on it they want
to shop around like it's going to go on
YouTube yeah I'll tell you now
it's gonna go to YouTube Yeah I'm
every streaming service has three of
this
oh right they have this guy right so I'm
not gonna be the guy but I just think
YouTube does better yeah I mean there's
like there's like Prestige I guess on
that but I don't who cares yeah I mean I
do think YouTube is kind of the best
place for a special now we want eyeballs
yeah that's it I forget like it took me
a while to realize that people watch
YouTube like TV oh because I'm like an
old man that's not sitting there doing
but yeah people put it on TV and just
sit there I'm like still looking at on
my phone thinking like well people's
gonna watch they're gonna watch the
whole special on the phone's like no
they put on their TV they're more they
know how HDMI cables work in their home
and they can put them like oh yeah
people do that I'm the one because I
think I live a certain way that's
however exactly and we're getting older
so it's a whole new generation I'm
hanging out with my niece I put on TV
she's like what is this and I'm flipping
through it she's like this is a this is
way a waste of time and she's right yeah
you're like commercial correct weather
you know uh it's a lifetime oxygen she's
doing the same thing Netflix she's just
scrolling like she can't decide what to
watch true but it's not like C-SPAN you
know and all these other boring yeah I'm
not stopping on like
the
car restoration show yeah Spike just
because this is what I've convinced
myself I like because I'm sick of
looking for something in the hotel room
right right
there's a FanDuel Network there's like
networks you've never heard I know
Encore stars all that [__] and it's just
such a it's so primitive you just feel
like oh this is like a VCR now or
something because there's something fun
about like I just got cable back for the
first time in like I like never had
cable it's been forever and yeah uh and
it's like there's something fun about
like coming into Cape Fear like that's
true that's true there's something kind
of cool about that that's like the radio
now this is like the one of the lonelier
things I've ever realized but like
sometimes I like like if I haven't been
on the road in a while and I turn on the
TV and Mario Lopez is there I'm like oh
hey Mario I haven't seen you in a while
yeah I got my pal Mario is going to tell
me what's what's happening on TV today
good to see you're still at it all right
that's a real Road [__] yeah you know
like AC Slater we grew up together I
like that you're still doing this
whatever it is I don't imagine if
Screech were still alive and he was
doing the road he just turned that on
he's like oh [__] oh yeah good point
yeah he went to porn he went to Comedy
yeah did you ever work with Screech no
did you no Dustin Diamond I remember uh
I did a porn with him once yeah well
that's how we you know
the level people understand the hustle
you know that was uh it was an unpaid
porn what's the sketchiest thing you did
early on thinking it was gonna oh I
almost I almost wore a giant penis
costume really for uh like or the early
days of the internet where it's like
just putting up put out anything like
2003 or something whoa we're gonna put
you in this giant penis costume you're
gonna go out and you'll be on like the
Santa Monica Pier interviewing people
and I was just like
I don't know good for you man I would
have done it I yeah and then I talked to
thank you gracias oh you didn't you
didn't do it though no it's like one of
the few things
my dad was like I don't know
you got a good dad I did a dating show
that was really embarrassing this guy
was like he saw my comedy he's like I'll
pay you if you do this dating you just
go on a couple dates and be funny on it
and I was like okay and then I was like
this is so bad I saw it yeah this is so
[__] oh really yeah yeah I was on a
car ride with a guy he was a comic and
he was like what do you think about me
doing naked and afraid I got an offered
and I was like don't do it that's crazy
you're gonna be naked on TV for the rest
of your life and he's like I already did
it
so he's on that
I never yeah that show I was like what's
the
that's the point of all this
so the show is that he's just he's stuck
in the woods or something yeah real
sunburned eating leeches yeah a lot of
mosquitoes how much money do you get if
you win is there winning is it was the
same guy every week or is a new person
wait actually this is the one where
you're naked on a dating show oh maybe
I'll get the name wrong what's the one
with the dating shows like naked it
could still be naked and afraid for the
woman it might be yeah all right there's
a naked attraction maybe that was it I
don't know either way it was on VH1 and
it was a real Dating Naked that was it
he did that and he's a good looking guy
but is it stand up can we look through
the credits and see oh yeah it was Doug
key really yeah yeah you do that I was
TV you know TV is so alluring when
you're when you're a young comic do they
blow your dick or yeah they do see
but somewhere out there it's not blurred
yeah in Europe
China everything's blurred yeah Japan
yeah they blur the porn over there
that's they just make Japanese porn
there's nothing at risk
that's not bad
you'll stand out well remember when it's
like all reality shows are gonna be
every like just
like I was glad I didn't do anything
where it was like my name yeah my real
name boom Larry that's our buddy and
he's in good shape he's in good shape
very good shape
it didn't help him or hurt him so it was
fine no I had a friend who went on uh
Judge Judy whoa that seems kind of fun I
think that's way that that's kind of
funny like kind of funny were they in on
it like yeah yeah oh no they knew that
she was a comic and they knew the other
guy was oh that's great it was pretty
funny actually they
some of them seem kind of real and some
of them are straight clown ass and I
think I think it's a healthy mix like
Jerry Springer R.I.P to that guy that
was like a mix of
sketch people in Chicago would get
booked on it but then my sister's friend
was the talent Wrangler oh boy for some
of and she's like not all of it some of
them are the real deal wow and as a
talent Wrangler it's just her that makes
me at five in the morning like I'm going
out for cigarettes like you can't leave
the hotel that's like you know they're
going out like get drugs or fight
hookers like please don't you have to we
have to have you at the studio in two
hours I kind of like oh that sounds like
hell I'm gonna get a gig in Showbiz and
on your talent Wrangler for Jerry
Springer chasing people around the
streets because they're looking for
I spent a whole morning with them once
because he uh really Jim and Sam were
doing like uh they were like we're on
vacation when you guest host it'd be you
and Jerry Springer and I was like [__]
yeah yeah and then they were like you
can bring a friend so I just brought
Greg stone with us sure and he was the
nicest dude like I loved him oh yeah he
was a politician he was a country singer
he's lived that guy yeah he was a
country yeah I didn't know that for a
while yeah I mean if you try to pay for
a hooker with a check
as the mayor of a town that sounds good
yeah I'm gonna say you're gonna get
country song out of that one there he
goes can we play a a few Tunes oh that's
like later in life oh yeah I think he's
Jewish
there's a I mean he is he is the rare
country singing Jew
doctor talk oh so he was capitalizing
off of the show already
ah sorry Jerry yeah I just want to
tackle him like you know yeah you don't
have a
you know on the show they all said
before you go out there you know you
can't fight you're not allowed to fight
on the show and they all go of course of
course then they would fight immediately
every time but they wanted enough yeah
yeah yeah the bouncer got his own show
Steve
I watched a lot of Springer that was the
guy's name Steve yeah bald guy yeah and
he got his own show he's just a clumsy
weirdo yeah that's how big that show was
that you could spin-off character
security got a gig yeah
so you're cheating on him ah
that was it was him kind of disapproving
yeah
there he is
wow this is Steve Harvey's doing a judge
show no judge Steve Harvey Jesus Christ
that guy's cashing in how I've always
what do you think like the health
regimen of somebody at that like that
guy is all over
like you're doing five TV shows like
what kind of access or like these like
like a Madonna or something it's like 60
and gonna do a stadium tour like
what are you like what are you taking to
do that I know I want to know about rich
people
like black market Healthcare oh I see
you mean like like workout regimen sees
a trainer she's a doctor or maybe that's
just how lazy I am how are you doing
like two things in the day
what's your secret daytime I saw a thing
that Nikki Glaser posted the other day
and she was like she was like I'm on
Jimmy Fallon's like singing shows like
Jimmy Fallon has a singing show yeah
what is this guy having your own late
night show is a lot of work oh yeah
right I got another show these guys
never stop when they'll die yeah
Seacrest was uh yeah going Coast to
Coast for gigs yeah
I think there will well first of all
they're all on ozembic you know about
this what's that the weight loss drug
the weight loss Barclay lost all that
weight you're gonna do a needle you know
no really yeah a lot of people took it
and I mean you just shed weight I think
Shaq took it too yeah that's great but I
thought Mark Wahlberg was like he's like
you shouldn't do that you know you
should [__] wake up at 4am like me
yeah should just punch a brick wall you
should just blind to Vietnamese yeah it
gives me ABS you know ABS the guilty
it's a way to Fat because I know I might
not go to heaven
yeah everybody's got through I mean
Biden and Trump I think are hooked on
Adderall that's I like like presidential
like you wake up here's five shots a
bunch of pills like as a present like
you're gonna fly to this country You're
Gonna Fly here you're gonna run the
country or is it secretly the easiest
gig because everybody else is in charge
exactly and you're like just speaking
every day though it's got to be hard
that's what we do we do and it is
yeah I'm gonna shut the [__] up for
about a month after this run
so uh you're doing a lot of podcasting
yeah my voice already sounds like this
and now it echoes in my head it's not
great yeah it's not the Acoustics you
desire it's way depressed for a special
is so much harder than stand up oh it's
a nightmare because the stand-up is Fun
the press it feels like I mean this
doesn't feel like work because we get
drunk on it but like they're doing other
podcasts sometimes I'm like holy [__]
it's it's a lot you gotta like drum up
stuff oh well and it's like what's like
if it's like well what's the what's the
bit that we're doing or if I don't know
people right and like I yeah I think I
can get to be in person but we're
talking about being introverts and
everything it's like all right we gotta
do this yeah to talk you see the AI come
that like beer commercial that they made
with AI no
well it's all like yeah it's like
grotesque kind of like everything's off
like how an AI does stuff that's what
like comedy podcasting feels like to me
is because I'm just like it's all is
this this is us that is a commercial
before the fake commercial that the
robots made you go oh my god oh weird
yeah just the faces whoa yeah
this is what this gives me hope though
that AI is not good yet oh I mean not
yet but this is all fake and this is
just
this is what uh doing press feels like
yes that's great that's great
whoa this is weird I don't like this is
dream [__] yeah it's kind of creepy
right oh yeah pause it there what are
they doing what's going on what the [__]
what beer was it
I think they made up a beer
oh there's Will Smith
oh my God
I don't like this [__] it makes me feel
weird yeah yeah it should
I hope that it makes more people feel
weird yeah we aren't like sexy enough
you know like
[Music]
remember that commercial what pull that
one up man just was it cool Coors Light
commercial we're just talking about how
like you know Bud Light had the Dylan
Mulvaney thing and we're just like look
at some beer ads from like the early
2000s and how different they were put
pull this one up wildly different yeah
look how much things have changed yeah
this is a kid rock video yeah yes
[Laughter]
the twins
that was a difference what year was that
I think 2001. somebody at an advertising
firm did not think that was funny at all
they're like crushed a team yeah fellas
you nailed it I think this ad is why 911
happened I think that's why they
attacked I could understand that their
values are incorrect they don't align
with our with Muhammad
the way they just Pander though he used
to football it's like oh holy [__] it's
perfect oh yeah that was a hit I mean
we'd walk around school going and twins
don't forget the twins yeah that was a
big deal
is that still like a hot thing
it's a myth because they're sisters
they're not gonna I mean it's not not
hot but it's just not like my thing it's
like if I saw it I'd be like yeah the
top but it's like the thing that you
always said was the thing to prove that
you weren't gay
uh with like twins like like when you're
a kid you don't even know what sex is
like [__] twins dude right I remember
yeah that I mean obviously lived in La
long enough and seeing women that get
the plastic surgery like oh you're
trying to look like what the gay kid
describes in seventh grade to prove he's
into later oh I like big juicy titties
yeah like lips that are just big big
juicy lips and titties because like oh
you yeah we don't know that it's okay
for you to be gay all right so you're
gonna lie and then a woman's like I'm
gonna I'm gonna pay money to look like
that yes that's uh off-putting to me but
I mean if you feel better about your
body but yeah like twins give me give me
two of them give me relatives like come
on guys can we think this one out okay
fine cousins all right stop it stop
using your imagination about sex you're
never gonna [__] don't worry about it
all right and friends yeah that's better
and there's two of them also it is if
you're having a threesome with twin
that's kind of incest it is insane it's
incest yeah yeah but they're doing it
with each other yeah right so yeah you
got to pretend that they're fighting and
you're trying to break it up
it's the only way that Jesus will let it
happen
is he looking get it hey ladies put your
clothes on you're not mad at each other
anal God's hole I mean incest is like
the new porn thing though it's like it's
all Step Brothers good point good point
incest right that's number one I can't
lie anything that looks like if she's
under 30 I'm gonna get it out of here
yeah
I mean I don't even need to just just a
woman that seems like she's there of her
own accord sure right that's that just
that just yo you've made a choice as an
adult yeah and you're okay with it like
that feel like well I mean I needed to
feel consensual in the porn like it
needs to feel like
I want to be like oh you got caught
shoplifting no just
just call the cops I don't know it's not
Punisher with sex doesn't feel good your
first gig all right yeah don't give me
any stories no no but that's how I feel
like I've gotten DMS on the road where
girls like you want to come over to my
hotel and [__] me I'm like this is
actually all I needed just the fact that
you will [__] me I'm good I don't need
to [__] you yeah the consent is hotter
than the set yes exactly I had a recent
one this is a maybe I shouldn't share
this but I was getting a text I got a
random text from a random number and I
was like what's this and it was a naked
lady and I was like oh and she's like
hey Roger come over and I was like uh oh
a trap this is a wrong number so I go oh
you know I'm kind of over you I'm just
[__] with her and she's like come on
you know I give the best head I'll suck
you dried I'm like will you though and
I'm just like going with it just you
know I'm at a restaurant I don't give a
[__] and she keeps sending crazier
videos now she's spread the legs she's
playing stuff she's got the tits what
restaurant were you there
Bob's Big Boy and uh so then I'm like I
don't know I'm a little bored with you I
got a new girl down the block she's even
better and she's like what I'll kill her
here how about this and she's sending
more and more videos and it's getting
like sad so I feel bad I go look it's
the wrong number I feel bad I can't I
can't do the charade anymore go find
Roger wrong number and she goes well
what what's your story and I was like oh
wow I was like I'm just a comedian in
New York she's like you want to come
over and I was like oh this is horrible
so I just deleted her that was a trap
from number from the get-go yeah oh
really absolutely
the wife
I don't know if you've seen but that's a
trap
there's no there's no dude's name Roger
uh yeah well it's like Drew Rogers
especially you don't just start with
nude pictures well they seem to know
each other pretty well I'm thinking to
make sure uh-oh somebody tried to do
that on Instagram I was like nah really
nah what's out there nah Russian bot I
don't know I wanna before we went on a
day she just sent me she was very like
aggressive send me a picture of a guy
getting blown with a finger up his ass
whoa and I was on a flight I was shocked
the picture came through but uh
in-flight Wi-Fi but uh yeah but it was
like aggressive I was like this is like
too much for me she was like do you want
this to happen to you and I was like
yeah but I don't want that to be your
opener I don't know right do I know the
guy right
yeah that's so how was that was the
second it didn't didn't happen really
yeah it was too pushy I get turned off
but I like to I like to be the aggressor
I like to do that
but uh interesting so you didn't pursue
because of the photo
yeah yeah probably oh wow fascinating
any anytime someone's aggressively
yeah it just makes it less attractive
you want to be the one who at least you
want what you can't you want to pursue
you want to chase yeah I don't know I
was always like passive about it oh yeah
I'm like this you're choosing this
you're a wild one
wow odd taste but okay I know that's why
it's like the little Chris Rock joke
it's like whenever I get some [__] I'm
like it's my lucky day you know as a
single guy that was how I felt I was
like oh my God I can't believe anyone's
willing to yeah it was always that like
oh you like me what's wrong with you
yeah that's a big show [__] right yeah
yeah like like what the [__] yeah you
almost don't trust him a little bit yeah
totally totally I'm glad I'm out of the
loop
single man right now I'm in the
beginning of something so yeah I've been
nine years in yeah I know yeah yeah yeah
yeah and I'm like
I look at like what's going like oh God
God bless you boys out there I know
white boys in the field it's a tough
score it's a scary out there scary
sending you off to war yeah landmines
everywhere watch out for Charlie yeah
it's fun all right let's be careful yeah
well you just never know who would get
who gets mad and then they twist [__]
and turn [__] yeah you can't live your
life that way all right
thank you
holy [__] you're welcome we're finding a
new Talent
he's going Mike
[Music]
there's a single clap Applause that was
the status rebuttal of all time it was
just one penny in the fountain is what
that was I was Will Smith you were Chris
Rock
well I will have my revenge all right
yeah please everyone called him a [__]
Charlemagne called him a bear that was
my Chris Rock going after Will Smith
that was some weird uh weird gimmick do
you have anything to bothering you
lately like peeves or anything
I got some lined up I'm trying to be
better about not being like I I think I
am pretty high strung about a lot of
[__] and I'm trying to lighten up about
it because of like what like
you know what I think it's the fact that
I will lay awake at night just
oh he said this and you did this and you
don't like and like my bad with my phone
just lay there looking at things I don't
want to interact on my phone but I just
yeah I found Reddit I was never another
guy oh careful it sucks man like I mean
it's evil it can be like like everything
can be curated yeah your interests and
be uh useful but it's the internet we
know it's not that it goes into
reading the horrible comments and then
like oh I'm being like I'm being fed
these things that are gonna make me this
guy I'm gonna get angry about these type
of politics even though I was
indifferent right and then I'll wake up
in the morning and I'll look at it
almost it's three hours I'm laying in
bed and I'm angry at the world like oh
this didn't nothing about my world
changed except I wasted three hours yep
read some [__] that I'm not gonna do
anything about it right but now it's
gonna paint my view of the day so I
think I'm just angry at my lack of
self-control that's what it is but
that's benefit
yeah it's been decades that makes sense
I do the same thing Reddit is poison I
mean it's really oh yeah I get real
honest how'd you how do you get around
it like I would love to know a way that
you get around it I didn't even open it
I met the guy I met the guy who ran it
because I did everything he hosted he's
a really nice guy I [__] on him pretty
hard because he was hosting the thing I
immediately was just like zinging him
yeah he's like I know I know bad about
it I put poison in the world
yeah but uh
yeah I mean it's just look you're gonna
look sometimes but you can limit it you
can just get like when you're looking
you can catch yourself but uh sometimes
you know what I think is like instead of
reading a book or something I'm I'm
reading with just random people are
writing and it's just vitriol it's just
boring on my nightstand collecting dust
and I'm like you're gonna read this at
night you're not gonna look at your
phone yeah I put my phone on top of the
book
yeah we've choked the book out yeah
Reddit is it's like 4chan light it's
scary there's a lot of scary people on
there but just you just can't look at it
how about this for a pave you ever have
this guy the guy who wants a photo with
you but he calls you over he's like oh
oh comedian come here come here let me
get a picture let me get a picture I'm
like you want to pick you come to me I
gotta go to you now he's like sitting at
a table he's like come here come here so
now I'm like a puppy like oh okay I'm
going over to you and then he's like hey
you're you're pretty good yeah what's up
what's it Mike yeah Mike yeah yeah I'm
like all right thank you I came to him
I was walking home it was the it was
raining I was walking home I passed the
guy in the car go Sam picture picture I
was like it's raining uh you're in a car
yeah and it was like 20 feet behind me
[__] that is it
like that seems like a very New York
kind of thing the New York thing bro
come here definitely exactly I like that
I have kind of
introverted fan like in a mix of like
drunk
dudes that are like self-conscious about
being like aren't confident about being
drunk they're like hey man
[Laughter]
and I was like I like you like can we
get a selfie I'm like you caught a
picture please yeah like okay can you
take a selfie for us well now it's not a
selfie right now it's a photo like but
it's not like I'm still in that mix of
like I can't go do you guys go out after
show like out in the crowd after shows
do you need people no no not really
anymore I don't know how to manage it
it's too much that's harder than the
show it's way more work yeah and I just
I've been trying to spread the word like
I'm so glad everybody's there but I
don't know how to hang out but okay
people who listen to this are awesome
our people with listeners are really the
best a lot of people are watching
special because you guys recommended it
so thank you for that yeah it's it's
like uh
they're really well-behaved drunks
that's the funny thing is like they're
all drinking so much of the shows but
they're that's they're really good drums
that's what I that's what I like yeah
like okay like I'm same thing I'm a guy
that's gonna have drinks
I was a [__] a few times and I
remember that part yeah yeah but same I
give friends you know the high school
friends I was just in New Orleans back
home and they were like man you gotta
you used to like black out you don't
black out anymore they were saying like
a bad thing like come on what happened
to you you got you got all queefy up
there in New York and I'm like I don't
know I don't want to black out and drive
and forget where I am and you know fall
down and lay on the sidewalk yeah I've
grown up I feel like there's there's
always maybe a couple not as many
anymore that feel like disappointed that
you won't do a shot with them yes and
I'm like if that's what determines
whether or not you want to stay being a
fan good point I'll cut my loss good
point also there's some there are nights
when I'm like I feel like doing a shot
but I'm more of a sipper than a shooter
I'm more I'd rather sip on it but then
if somebody sees me do one then somebody
else wants to do one yeah and now I feel
like if anybody wants to buy me a drink
I'm like oh thank you but they're giving
them to me for free because then there's
like what about you drink
now I feel like they expect some sort of
like obligation to hang out I'm like yes
I said all the stuff I want to say now I
don't have the social skills completely
this afterwards because like I want to
talk like somebody wants to say
something like oh you know comedy got me
through a rough time like oh that's
sweet and then a drunk person comes in
from three o'clock like look we're gonna
do a drink and then somebody's like oh
canaanes out there I'm like oh but this
person was saying something sweet but
also you bought a ticket too right and
I'm like I got a veggie platter in a
green room
saving the broccoli for after because
broccoli is my favorite with the little
ranch dip so I'm gonna just sit back
there until everybody's empty the whole
building your veggie platter with the
ranch yeah because I know I'm gonna eat
like [__] right every other moment so in
the Green Room like give me some
vegetables to my rider that's it yeah
yeah like only healthy things in the
Green Room yeah because I'm gonna get
like a large pizza that I'll eat in bed
me and Mario Lopez are gonna split a
large pie I have like nuts Pepto uh in
the veggie platter then
I know that's why it's like I'm just
gonna house this hole and not even if I
don't need fancy yeah cheap one with a
dip in the middle big old cellophane
yeah it's cherry tomatoes baby boy we
[__] party guys yeah no more blowing
rails in the green room that's the thing
if you were like oh you're coming to
Memphis I got a guest room I got a snake
I got a a pool you know above ground
pool we can we can live it up man I
won't bother you you can just come by
I'll cook for you but I won't bug you
and you're like why would I want to do
that I got a hotel but the people
they're just so optimistic maybe I
realize people don't know the other side
of it sure people are like let me buy
you a drink because it'd be they feel
good like like you paid for a ticket
that's all you needed to do yeah that's
all you need I'll give them a drink
usually good I'll bring Bodega cat on
the road so I'll just be like here I got
you a drink I'm sipping mine I'm not you
know doing shots yeah right if I got
drunk every night oh like even Guns and
Roses probably had a like all right
thank you Minneapolis yeah boys I got a
yoga DVD
let me get a Seltzer yeah take it easy
slash you're gonna make that good
Mediterranean pasta
I'm gonna have a real easy one tonight
all right gonna watch Sleepless in
Seattle right
I gotta watch your pocket what time yeah
I did The Bert Chrysler but fully loaded
we'd watch movies get drunk overnight
and one night I was like let's just
watch a movie and we watched Apocalypto
and smoked weed and it was like it was
so nice because it's called fully loaded
you're with these [__] animals Joey
Diaz and Gillis and all these crazy big
J and you're like let's just watch a
movie once we've been on the road for 12
days drinking too long for like the
sleepover days oh yeah I know what you
mean yeah give me a stick of celery well
Bert's the oldest one there and he's
[__] going he's drinking them up it's
going nuts yeah I was joking with
somebody I wonder if like when Bert
finally gets a night off he just puts on
all his shirts
They just won for every night he's had
to take one off like this is all I
wanted this is all I really want that's
his rape show that's his life yeah I
love myself
that's hilarious all right one more
fever then I'll leave you guys I got
something you got one let me see what
um
hmm and we'll we'll wrap things up let
me see what I got
um oh this is more me being stupid so I
was seeing this this is a p but it's
more like me just kind of venting almost
we're like I started seeing a girl and
you ever just like recommend a show to
someone she's like I need a show to
watch while we're apart I was like oh
we're going through classic shows I was
like Mad Men that's a great show and
she's like oh I've never seen that she
binges it like four seasons in like two
weeks which I'm like she's like now
everything she's saying is like how much
she hates men I'm like oh yeah you
needed a week in between oh an episode
from Batman wasn't meant to be [__]
she's watching like Don Draper [__] like
47 different women right right she's
like he's a bad person I'm like yeah
that's the show I did the same thing and
had the same reaction because I binged
it and then
when shows are meant to be spaced out to
like that's part of the drama and I did
the same thing and I'm like
all it is is like oh God I [__] I
[__] this lady again but I'm sad I'm
like I don't give a [__] dude yeah
you're a gorgeous man he's rich I get
through oh your past is rough but oh I
guess I fell in some [__] again this
week like yeah it was hard for me to
build up because it wasn't
compartmentalized so I totally
understand that yeah it's written for a
time when you it was on age yeah when I
picture you a woman and have trust
issues with men and then you're dating
me oh it's a lot and yeah you
recommended Mad Men I didn't think of it
I was just like it's like I'm thinking
like Sopranos is the greatest thing I've
seen that no no skip that's it let's
find something that's gonna work yeah
you sent her some brown she's like I
[__] hate Italian the worst people
that greasy and murderers oh I love
Sopranos she's like clearly likes it
she's still watching it but I'm like
like Tony kills people I know you know
but I'll do the same thing like I'll
just get into it because like when I'm
off the road I'm off the road oh yeah
yeah because again like when you guys
are off the road you're here you're
never off
yeah you're in town and you're gonna be
getting a little splash thank you thank
you
okay yeah you're not like that's why I
was I was hanging out with Sean Patton
and and Shane Torres and I'm like
because we're talking about being
introverts I'm like where do you go to
be alone yeah in this city and Sean's
like well you know like this part in
Prospect Park where you can like walk
off into a path and I just go take a
phone call you know I can like uh talk
on the phone but I'm like that's not
alone like you're on the phone in some
bushes like I don't know like I like I'm
true like where's like outside of noise
canceling headphones and a weighted
blanket how do you feel yeah you like an
old school comic where you're like I
feel like you romanticize being in a
hotel room just away from everything I
when I'm not like I'm obviously the
Oregon thing was pandemic but even in La
I was like all day I was like you know I
got into like bike ride and stuff and so
I [__] off into the mountains that was
my thing like in the daytime was to go
just riding in the mountains but like
truly by myself to a point where like
you'd crash you'd be like ah wish I had
a friend yeah yeah that's cracked and
I'm not making it out of this Valley but
uh
like where like that's my those are my
days really and and maybe I got a little
too used to it because now I come here
and I'm just
oh like I'm the guy on the sidewalk like
what are you honking at right you're not
doing anything it's not affecting
anything and I'm like I look like the
crazy one right because somebody's just
like uh it's better than feeling
something
I'm the opposite I'm in a quiet place
and I'm like where the [__] the noise
the noise is almost like common to me
this is fascinating I'm also a city I
grew up here so it's like oh you grew up
in the city yes oh okay okay that will
make me like the the non-fast pace I'm
in a slow City like in the South and I
freak the [__] out you know that's yeah
cause we're in the suburbs I didn't
realize I had like mild tinnitus till we
moved to Oregon is that an ear thing
yeah like what's that noise I'm like oh
that's my brain
serious it's just when there's truly no
noise like truly truly not even air
conditioned or something it's like this
low level it's not bad for me but it's
like this low level like you know when
you do a hearing test and they'll do
like like you know get to this frequency
where you hear it but you're like I
barely hear it that's all I hear whoa
but it's only
when it's completely quiet I would never
hear it I would never know I had it here
I didn't know I had it in LA yeah but
Oregon just laying there at night wow
like what's going on
but it's a different like here there's
like maybe gunshots or fireworks or car
horns like you're one like we first
moved up there I had like a stick break
in the yard I'm like they're [__]
coming in like I got extra paranoid
about stuff yeah oh no actually
nothing's happening around right right
one weird guy walking down the street
what's he up to like there's a guy with
a needle like in front of your building
here yeah then I'm gonna get somebody it
looks clean I hope you're doing it safe
I live next to like a drug recovery oh
no I didn't know when I started renting
the place but uh after a certain point I
was like man there's a lot of drug
addicts outside my apartment then every
day like man another another pack of
drugs yeah and I'm like yep there we go
they're working on it crazy how fast you
adapt to the city you're like man
there's a hobo here and a crackhead here
and but then you just go ah there's Jeff
and there's the crack at you like you
just get it now that was I was like
doing a joke about how you start saying
stuff with way too much nonchalance like
oh that guy with the swords out in front
of them
maybe that should be something that's
more addressed and not just accepted
like welcome into the fold sword guy
yeah yeah that's what this thing does I
was walking with a woman and she's like
let's go she's walking I was like don't
go that way there's a lot of rats and
she was like what oh yeah there's a pack
of rats that always walks up I know they
all get the same jacket I think they're
in a gang I was here with Rachel one
time and I I forget where we're walking
and she was like hopscotching over so
much vomit it was like a Saturday night
and something like party area and she's
like bopping around she's like I can't I
know we're not that far but let's get a
car to the hotel all right so we get the
car and she just puts she gets out of
the car but puts one foot on the ground
and screams I'm like barf she goes dead
rat
hey
I've read that like the most expected
thing that could happen but with a
little twist
better than a live rat I think because I
could run up yeah they run up yeah Oh
They'll Scurry up your leg I've gotten
them bouncing off my shoes a couple
times it's they're cocky here oh yeah
they're Fearless they'll come up on the
leg you respected a little bit too
because you're like yeah [__] he's got
some balls you know yeah if you're
stationary they'll run up yeah but if
you're moving you're good if you stop
stay moving stay moving stay moving they
can't see if you move I remember I saw a
woman walking dogs once and she kept
stomping I was like I was like Excuse Me
Miss why are you stomping and she goes
it scares the rats away and I saw a
bunch of rats Scurry away
oh here we go hold on hold on real quick
there's a guy sleeping on the subway oh
what's that goes right up the leg tell
me it takes his wallet
here yeah right
what if that's his rat oh he woke up man
he took that well oh no how do you just
feel
okay wow he took that really well that
would have [__] screamed like a lady
I like the I like that rat though yeah
the rat was a truck but see I can't
criticize this even though I want to
because now I just want to start feeding
crows in my neighborhood oh well crows
are smart
Brad seemed pretty smart he got on the
subway that's true good point how'd that
rat note there's just too many of them
whoever rats are now
Adams is a point to the rat oh like I've
heard of Rat Kings but I feel like
there's red stars it's a woman who's
supposed to do away with the rap problem
really so that's like the new she got a
special flute
St Patrick
[Laughter]
videos oh yeah this is a pro oh he's
he's eating out of his mouth oh my gosh
that damn man that one I didn't need to
see this that one is that was baby
burden it was baby bird dog oh you don't
do that in Portland huh
you know what I would like to think that
somebody would do not just film it yeah
right hey there's rats eating out this
guy's mouth who's got the best phone
here who's got 4K right like I I would
hope
okay you know I hear all this you know
West Coast is like nice but not kind but
east coast is kind but not nice these
videos are not proving that that's true
this is like hey take this rat giving
this guy uh whatever disease you get
from rap yeah you don't help but yeah
yeah you do get a tick tock look at that
oh my God that's something that's
aggressive right that's a rogue rad he's
a ballsy that's crazy
but then like
[Music]
yeah this is good trash follow me guys I
can't wait for the red it was like hey I
got chocolate bars I'm gonna I got a
baseball team uniforms you wanna see me
moonwalk give me a buck
like he basically has given him a kiss
there that is pretty rough oh yeah well
it's yours all right like didn't
somebody just choke out a guy on the
subway here but rats they're like nah
let him go
priority that's CBS News That's CBS that
even CBS needs click bait
CBS his rat climbs up sleeping Subway
Rider come on guys I know it's I know
it's ad base these days but they'll be
fun if the rats like I need content you
know yeah I need a clip and CBS is like
we do too listen we're gonna put you on
the L train do your thing we got a guy
on the inside all right look back tag me
yeah
all right hey uh stock uh sorry I'm
drunk shocks and struts did I get that
right that's the stuff is that the one
it's on that's it's on the same website
we're watching rats climb up on people
that's why I got more views no offense
of course it does of course we just
watched it nine times it's yeah I
haven't watched my special once I
watched it it's killer one of the best I
loved it thank you watch watch Kyle's
stuff right now truly uh great comic
great comic and there's uh there's a lot
of backlog he's got some Netflix he's
got some Comedy Central I remember first
album I remember the trader Giotto bit I
mean great [__] [__] that was big
truly a great comment back when you can
it's kind of sliding slide around that
kind of material oh yeah extra stuff but
watch watch and and listen all this
stuff one of the best Comics workers so
killer and see him on the road anything
coming up oh yeah oh here we go we got a
lot of things what is this yeah I'm out
forever this will be out in June I think
we're June 11th I'm a tour forever and
then hide the rest of the dates that you
don't see there there you go uh which
helium are we talking here because
there's a lot of healing okay there we
go oh it's a new one I guess they're
calling it St Louis oh okay I love this
trend of comedy clubs being named after
the city they're 45 minutes away I know
right that's a Liberty Township but they
call it Cincinnati oh my God that's like
45 minutes outside Cincinnati everyone's
tweeting me like [__] you this isn't
Cincinnati yeah Richmond Funny Bone is
like yeah like well yeah sorry it's a
it's a mall western Pennsylvania I don't
know where I am right now I don't like
Richmond though actually the city no the
city's great they got it they got this
uh Jewish deli called pearlies I show
you know it's like the best great day
I've ever been here you think if you're
gonna be a Jew in the South you got to
step it up yeah
we're gonna win you over
you got an idea about us we're cheap
look at all this
oh sandwiches
elite elite Jewish food very nice it's
like don't say don't say it don't say
Elite and Jews yeah you're right that's
[__] up you're gonna we're
backtracking on what I say they control
all the delis I'd be okay with that
see Kyle on the road getting Bodega cat
whiskey Bodega catwhiskey.com I think
I'm gonna be in like yeah Denver uh
Santa Fe San Antonio Houston all over
I'll see you on the road samuel.com
Ellie I'm still in Australia doing I
think the last time I saw anybody with
Australia yeah I was just there last
month oh yeah oh I can't wait I'm
excited going out there hitting all the
cities
um so yeah adding shows check out
markdormancomedy.com get Bodega cat we
got YouTube specials we got up [__] up
the yin yang thanks for listening we
might be drunk now we're gonna go
attempt to do sets in New York City
no thank you Kyle thank you
[Music]
and you will endanger us
woman doesn't look like I remember her
and I get down in the same way
we might
be true
[Music]